um i always say like he's this is like
my first like
lesbian relationship yeah okay and did
you view him
do you view him similarly similarly as
me where it's like
i find him attractive in all the ways
that i don't find a regular guy
attractive for hands down oh god
no no no no no no no no no no you can't
say
that what the [ __ ] you know what i'm
talking about
i know what you're talking about yeah
youtube i don't know what you're talking
about
you don't tell you
this is why oh my god this is why all
right go ahead
so g can i just let enough of the
questions
she has to answer this go ahead get back
all right he's like a lady
all right okay that's okay
but that's the thing but that he no i
like it
it's good let's just put it this way i
understand what you're saying yeah and
if you were to like
if you would like go towards a color
like it's it's almost he's a separate
little he's a little into entity of his
yeah
like that i will say that bobby it's not
bad
it's not bad but it's definitely
different from like being with a
[ __ ] plumber from arkansas like
you're
different it's a good thing that's a
good thing that is a good thing
that's a good rainbow
okay i want to keep the questions going
but um i just have to add
that um with that explanation yes
before i was a little defensive but with
that explanation i would have to agree
with that
okay good go ahead with questions not
that plumbers from arkansas are bad i
just want no no they're not just they're
not
no you can't get canceled with that
sarah i'm not trying to get canceled
well the guy that i dated last before
him was just big
burly athlete yeah and i
when i met him i was like why i couldn't
explain
why i was really attracted to him also i
remember your friends and family were
going what the [ __ ]
my my family wasn't like that they
weren't there was only one friend that
did that
yeah who was that and she was my ugliest
friend yeah yeah so she i think she was
just projecting
oh okay i don't think that it came from
anywhere beyond her own insecurities
about herself
um okay um what did you guys fight most
about
i don't remember fighting with you we
don't fight no fighting right
because i think the v was the video
games a problem
here can i say this though